all right Tania
Tania where'd you grow up where are you
from originally I'm from La
um West Adams district and just all over
the west side but that's where I first
grew up West Adams district
tell me about your family
my family
um
I grew up in a
it was my mom and my stepdad
um my dad was in jail like all my life
in and out of jail
so because my mom had me young at the
age of 15.
um and my dad was always in jail she was
like a single mom until she met my
stepdad
and I guess we were a happy family but
me personally I felt like
it wasn't really no love for my mom
because I don't know if she didn't like
me because of my dad and this is real
[ __ ] like I know we hear it a lot but
she just looked at me like you better
not turn out to be like your dad and she
was very strict so
you know grown up in a strict household
you know
you Rebel and that's what happened
you went to the streets
straight to the streets what age
at the age of 15 I kind of knew like
okay I'm not gonna be here
but I didn't want to do it in a
disrespectful way because I was always
respectful I was just looking for like a
way out
um
so I met a friend and she was my best
friend at the time and she knew what I
was going through my mom and my stepdad
and I just felt like you know my mom was
settling for Less with my stepdad so I'm
like you're always worried about him
I don't need to be here and
I got into my stepdad and then my best
friend was like you should just leave
and I'm like I know huh so I ran away
and when I ran away
my whole life just changed but I lost my
virginity first and then I ran away so
they think I ran away because they were
saying like
I'm gonna get a little vulgar oh you got
some dick you feel like you can leave
now like you feel like you grown now and
I'm like no y'all don't want me here
anyway that drag so I left and I just
started like making money doing whatever
I had to do because I had to survive
instrument what working the streets
that and whatever I could get my hands
on as far as money you know stealing
finessing
whatever
so you learn how to play men
exactly
really fast and it's like okay so when
people see you in the street you know
they kind of get an idea like oh this
girl ain't got no money so you want to
make some money or you need some money
you know and the opportunities just came
so fast because me I'm like I was mature
for my age too so
it was easy for me like I used to let
them know like how much you got like you
know what you got it was always with me
what do you have to give me I never just
let nobody just
you know use me it was always what can
you give me so I started getting getting
and it became addictive like
very addictive
so fast money oh yeah fast money
you know a lot of money for my age and
you know you get money fast you go
through it fast so you finish High
School yeah I finished high school so
when I was in the streets I still was
like I kept like a good communication
with my family because I didn't want to
burn them Bridges you know and my mom
wasn't happy because she didn't like how
I still was like surviving in the
streets she was like this girl thinks
she could just be out and do whatever so
me and her relationship was never
it's still not good and um no matter
like what I you know try to do like even
if I changed a little bit she's still
not going for it but
um
yeah like I kept I kept a good
relationship with everybody and
they just
they knew what was going on and couldn't
nobody stop it basically
but what did you ask me no basically
what you were doing so you started out
working the streets but you eventually
started doing other things and um yeah
like just at a at a certain level and
you know meeting new people meeting new
Hustlers they giving me the game and
just telling me like how I should do
things you work with them
have I worked with him yeah
um no they always tried to knock me
though all the time still to this
daylight
and I got to keep telling them like No
so at this point they like oh you a
renegade like you just do whatever you
want to do yep
so what are you doing currently you are
how would you describe it
I would describe My Life currently
I'm a finesser at heart I'mma always get
what I need to get but not in a bad way
you know like I said I'm I always come
with it like respectfully
um I'm straight to the point you know
you're not robbing your tricks yeah I'm
not robbing my tricks and I'm straight
to the point like they know what I need
and like you know I have kids now so
it's like to the point to where I need a
lot I get everything paid for like my
bins right now I don't pay for it my
rent I don't pay for it nothing I don't
but I still get money but certain things
they got to pay for So when you say
you're finessing men tell me what that
what that looks like
so finessing is
if you got the gift in the Gap like I do
to basically make somebody feel how they
need to be felt if that making sense
um whatever their needs are like you
know you you
give it to them but it's in the way to
where you could get so much out of them
because of what they need so you end up
getting more so like people think
finessing is like just tricking somebody
no my way I gotta finesse you the right
way because I need to keep coming back
for more and more and more it's not just
one time with me what does that mean
like telling the guy you need this to
pay your rent you need this too or like
you know yep all of that or just
basically saying like you know like I
can do this for you I could do that for
you and basically being like
unnecessary thing for these men
and they need it and I don't know what
it is about me but I got that certain
little touch baby to where
they always
a hoe on the street you're more of a
sugar baby exactly sugar baby
sugar baby
and that makes
you better money than working the
streets oh yeah
um it's more safer you know I don't got
to worry about because you know people
on the streets you deal with so many
weirdos creeps you can get hurt it's
like different diary every hour
every hour probably every even 30
minutes and at this point I need to have
like I said a relationship with people
so like I have like a like millionaires
NFL players
um
athletes doctors
real people
sugar daddies where you have it one time
I mean about over 10 at once really and
how long were these relationships last
they still going on
until maybe something like you know
there they don't have enough money or
because you know I'm not cheap
I'm really not cheap you know when I
first started I used to you know when
people first start
you get kind of like [ __ ] over and but
when I start realizing what my worth was
by the type of sugar daddies I was
getting I'm like wait a minute
I don't need to charge two or three
hundred I need to charge five and then I
need to charge a thousand oh this one
gave me 1500 so now
you know I'm getting more
and it's like it's like so easy to very
easy but you got to know what you're
doing now and it got to be a purpose you
know in these relationships are sexual
sometimes
yeah
sometimes
not always though not always
um I get lucky a lot to deal with people
who they're so busy and they just want
either somebody to talk to or you know
um I started a career in body rubs so
like I was making so much money with
that like I'm talking about a day 3 000
just easy body rubs all day long but
that's a sexual relationship it is it's
kind of like a girlfriend experience
type of thing
um you know they want a body rub once a
week
and you're seeing them a lot and like
they're giving you everything you know
on top of
gifts when you come
um body rubs um
oh let's go out to dinner it's more than
just you know these guys are married or
single or both both
and then I like when they're married too
because I'm like we can't do nothing
because you're married you know and it's
not like I wouldn't want to do nothing
like it's been a few guys where I'm like
dang like maybe I should just stop doing
this and I should be with them but then
I have to think like nah
you're a sugar baby stay in your lane
you've been in love before
a few times
has ever been a client
one of them I was falling for him but I
couldn't have them he was too he was
taken
and he was very successful and I loved
his whole house like imagine like me I'm
from the hood right so while me being
people think oh you're touching all this
money you're supposed to be living far
sometimes you don't sometimes you still
be stuck in the hood or
just going through life and like I said
fast money so like you're using it for
your needs and then you're you got to
spend your habit and kids and all this
is not how you really wanted to be but I
wanted to stay with him and he
see he was in a relationship but you
know they didn't live together so like I
would be there
for like a week sometimes you know and I
could come like in and out
and I love the whining and dining but it
just wasn't my life with him so I had to
like wake up
do you have a spending addiction
oh yeah
yes I do yeah what I've learned is
pretty much almost maybe all these women
yeah they do this kind of work have a
shopping or spending unit yes because
you got to look the part you know you
gotta you can't just go over there like
you think I'm getting
500 to a thousand dollars just for
looking like trash like I gotta keep
myself kept up always clean so you can
do that for less than a thousand dollars
you can you can you could look like a
you really can
you could do everything you need to do
with probably 300 right and then be done
for the the day or the week but
but it's addictive but you keep spending
keep spending and that's what you're
saving at all are you saving money at
all yeah so now I'm smarter now and of
course like because I know it comes fast
I make sure that I save you know
um I do
my priorities first of course and like I
don't have to spend so much I keep all
of my stuff together because oh when I
first started I would be leaving clothes
at people's house I'll be doing just
fast you know I'll get a phone call I
gotta leave I got the money already I
don't care about nothing I go over my
homegirl house I'll let some people wear
it it's like I was losing
a lot you lose a lot you gain a lot but
you got to be smart about it you have to
be smart about this [ __ ] because it
ain't as sweet as it look what are the
downsides of this lifestyle
did you thank you emotionally if it
affects me emotionally
um you feel like you're selling yourself
yes all the time and you're a sex object
right yeah like a sex slave you know and
it even got me into a situation before
where
I'm gonna say that in a minute but I
would feel bad because when I try to
date you know guys that thought in my
face they'll get mad oh you ain't
nothing but a hoe [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
how many [ __ ] you [ __ ] and saying
stuff like that so I'll be like oh you
wasn't thinking about that when we first
got with each other like boy boo but now
I understand
you know
they can only imagine what I tell them
they don't really know you know the real
reasons why or what really happens they
don't know because they wasn't there and
that would affect me most emotionally
but I got myself into a situation where
I was about to get sex trafficked and
this was like
this was like three years ago
and I was just like
it was a close one you know I I came up
on this Prince
and he was Arabian and
he flew me to Miami and he said I was
going to be there for two weeks
we were in a 30 million dollar house and
I ended up being there for a month and I
had to escape okay and we were meeting
so many girls and girls from Love and
Hip Hop was coming in the house and
celebrities was there and all of this
stuff but it started to get real weird
you know it was a lot of drugs and like
I don't do hard drugs like that like I
was smoking weed you know and they were
doing hard drugs and stuff and it was
just like it was getting like my gut was
telling me something bad is about to
happen
but
he was trying to like distract us what
buying this stuff was going shopping and
doing all these things and for some
reason I felt like like I'm used to
getting [ __ ] but like this right here
where I'm about to be tomorrow and why
are we still here so then he says well
we're gonna go to Cuba so the girls
start talking in the house and they're
like
girl I got to get back home and he said
that I can't leave and I'm like what is
he gonna do with us then you know we got
went to some celebrities house and we
ended up at P Diddy's house and I just
started hearing conversations and I just
got sex trafficking from it
because
you know I heard the prince saying
something like oh you can have whoever
you want like he was like selling guns
you know so I'm like
is this sex traffic like
what the
and it just it gave me a whole nother
outlook on everything too and I had to
like really like pump my brakes on how I
do things and maybe because a week
before that I had just said like I want
to be in Miami I want to be around
royalty I want a [ __ ] to spend this so
much amount and I realize everything
that I said that I wanted it came like
the next week but it didn't come how I
wanted it to and I don't like nobody
saying I can't leave you know when I
want to like if I get got to get back to
LA handle some business I'm a mother
like what you mean I can't leave so your
kids yeah yes
how many kids five kids you have five
kids yes so you need money to
to take care of them are you are you
raising your kids oh yeah I'm raising my
kids they're all with me
um but at a point in time I'ma keep it
real they wasn't you know what I'm
saying they are now they wasn't it was
it was always at my grandma house and my
mom house because I had [ __ ] to do and I
was in the music you know I was singing
with YG at that time
um and I had been for like a long time
but in and out of that the music wasn't
paying so I really had to finesse and I
would be meeting like people in the
industry and I'd be finessing them too
you know but I made sure with them we
would have like relations but I wouldn't
like have sex with them because I didn't
want it like coming up
like oh you [ __ ] that producer or you
did that right so I was real low-key but
they understood like you know you gotta
you got mouths to feed
but
at the end of the day
I've been through so much and I always
think like why do I do this [ __ ] like
you know I self-reflect with myself like
when I'm got my down time and I'm
looking at my kids and I'm like what
would I be doing if I wasn't doing this
and then I'll go back and say well how
did this start
and I came up
with and I didn't even realize it at
first
but while I was ran away and I was 17
. you know I was remember I told you I
was still going to school it was my
choice my friends none of them graduated
I had three best friends none of them
graduated three different best friends
like we went to different schools and
they still didn't graduate right and
I was like I got to get my [ __ ] together
right and I'm like I gotta you know get
my credits up and do all this my dad
gets out of jail from all this time here
I went to jail for manslaughter for
killing somebody with his bare hands and
um
he gets out he's looking for me they're
like she in the streets
so
he finds me
and he's like I want you to come live
with me I'm like okay but I'm looking at
him like
well I'm already in this school I don't
want to leave my school I'm trying to
get my credits up I can't go to a
regular school I'm at a continuation
school so he's like don't worry about
none of that long story short things
started getting weird with him I felt
the vibe I always had like this strong
intuition about me that's why it was
cool for me to go out to the streets
because I felt like I was safe like I
knew what was going to happen when to
stop you can read a guy quickly I could
read anybody quickly that's the thing
and I don't use it in a bad way I don't
try to take advantage but you know I
know what it is I know what's up I think
God gave me that
for real that's strong read your
intuition and tell you about your dad
okay so he's like
my gut is telling me like your God your
dad is about to try something so I had a
boyfriend at the time and he was like a
gang banger from 30s Harlem 30s right
and it seemed like my dad was jealous of
the boy and the fact that my dad just
got out he wanted to spend time with me
but I kept telling him listen on the
weekends I chill with my boyfriend so
he's like well what about me I'm like
okay well you just got out you know we
got to build that he told me you're too
hard you're too aggressive I'm your dad
so then he tells me like you can't talk
to this boy no more I'm like you can't
tell me 17. I'm like you can't tell me
what to do he like um
so are you guys [ __ ] I say yep he
lied
let me meet him he met him he tried to
beat him up threaten them do all this
stuff I got I get mad then he tell me
like listen I just need to sit you down
and tell you the real sat me down sat in
front of me just like this no shirt on
just boxes on this is my heart really
start racing like what is about to
happen he's like
you know not a lot of people know this
only a few people but I'm gonna share it
um he's like listen I'd rather you [ __ ]
me than [ __ ] any [ __ ] on the street
so I look like this some Jerry Springer
time [ __ ] so what is he about to do like
is he about to try me mind you he just
got out of jail for manslaughter so my
mind and my intuition is telling me go
along with it because if you don't he's
gonna rape you
so I'm like so what are you saying like
you want me to have sex with you my dad
said yeah
because I don't want you [ __ ] nobody
else if you want to have sex you could
[ __ ] me so I'm like
and so he raises up and I like see his
print in his boxes or whatever so I get
scared like oh my God like he's about to
force this [ __ ] on me so my mind telling
me if you just go along with it you can
run out
so I said no wait he like what you think
is too big for you I'm like this [ __ ] is
getting too real so I'm like no it's not
too big for me ain't nothing big for me
so I have to tap back into how I really
act instead of acting scared so
he went in the room I know I said so go
in the room I said go in the room I got
to get in the shower I gotta get ready
I'm like if you want to do this [ __ ] now
he like yeah and I'm like okay go in the
room so he went in the room I ran the
shower I called my best friend like
[ __ ] oh my God I'm about to come to
your house so I peeked in the room and I
seen him at the edge of the bed like
you know like he was contemplating or
thinking about something so I'm like
this [ __ ] and after that I just
ran out so of course you know he called
my phone like are you gonna tell anybody
so I end up telling my mom you know what
I'm saying and I wasn't even in her
household but I told my grandma first
and I told my best friend's mom then my
best friend's mom said tell your grandma
then my grandma said tell your mom and
my mom said
you can't never be around him again
period and we just never talked again so
the next year
that's when I you know first
you know had my um my son the next year
so I see my dad at a stop stop light
talking to a young girl and she was
pregnant she was a Hispanic girl she was
pregnant and she had a stroller and he
was talking to her and I'm like he's
still at it so maybe he just you know
like a creep and I just looked at guys
like they wasn't nothing and ever since
then I really started going in that's
when I started finessing people so I
realized like the anger with that like
this is how my dad turned out I'm about
to get everything that I could get from
every man and that's just all this to it
imagine if he would have penetrated my
head probably would have been [ __ ] up
so I looked at it like I got the one up
you know that's how I always looked at
things like I got the one up ain't
nobody about to have a one up on me
which it don't end up like that you know
you do get burned in the streets a lot
but that's what I thought and you
consider what you're doing you're in the
streets or are you dealing with a higher
caliber of man now I'm dealing with a
higher caliber of men where do you meet
men to finesse so everywhere you know
rich areas
um but before I started doing that I was
like in the streets just like random and
then um I could finesse anybody like you
don't even have to have I made people
who wasn't a trick a trick like they
literally they wasn't lying like they
didn't do all what they did I would
break their pockets I'm talking about
I don't care until you have nothing so
what get it again you got a job don't
you that was my mentality like I I never
worked
never and I've had a whole lot of stuff
I'm always taking care of you know
what's the most you've gotten from one
it's your day
um one night 2900 it was like Christmas
Eve
2900
and it was to the point to where he
asked me like do you have a friend I
called my friend she got like 2100 from
them and I'm like then I could have got
more but you it was cool
what have you learned about men from
living this life what I learned about
men is a lot of successful men and just
men period
they need love
they need love you know it's a void that
they're trying to fill in so
that's why I was always there like well
I could play the part you know I don't
I'm not a hoe I'm
somebody who makes you feel good you
know what's more important to Your Love
or Money oh love you know love I've
learned that love is
so much more important and I have gotten
so much more spiritual I was always
spiritual right and mature you know
people used to say oh you before your
time
but
even more now being through what I've
been going through what I've been
through
I mean I don't
if some stories that I can't even talk
about on this interview that's how crazy
they are you know and it's to the point
to where I look at people
much more than what I used to look at
them I used to look at them like nothing
because it was money over everything at
one point
I need the money I need the money and
then my dad even though he was a creep
he had like a reputation for having a
lot of money and you know being a dope
dealer and
you know he was a professional boxer but
he kept going to jail and they had me so
young my dad was 14 my mom was 15 when
they had me and by that time he was
already having like four and five cars
at a time selling dope I would go visit
them in prison and stuff like that and
so growing up without him I always
wanted to kind of be like him you know
like I want to have the money I want to
have the cars I want to have the name
and I did just about that you know
having the name having the money having
the cars
um ended up singing had the kids that I
wanted but
the way I was going about things I could
have got hurt too so I was trying to
stay off the street street but I'm
always in the streets I'm always
networking like even getting to these
people
I talked to one person we Network and I
get to the bag as we call it right I
would literally talk to oh you're a dope
dealer who you know who your clients who
your customers who you I will be all up
in everybody's Pockets trying to get
some because I need it and I know a
[ __ ] ain't gonna try to give it to me
so I gotta go and get it and I'm not
giving my money to nobody I didn't had
fights with pimps for not
giving them my money or if they see me
or you know get off the block
a few times I understood on these little
hoe Strokes like who's been to pull up
you know let me see what happens in 30
minutes I didn't did that before but
it's just not my style
kids have how many different fathers
so two so I have five kids I got two
other fathers in their lives
no
and
they somewhat in and out
but they like trying to figure out what
I'm doing I have the type of baby
fathers who don't even care about the
kids it's more like [ __ ] what you doing
they disrespect me a lot I went through
domestic violence with baby daddies and
stuff like that and that's why I really
just always finesse I'd rather be around
somebody who wants love that's why I end
up with these men I can't be around
nobody putting their hands on me and
that's traumatic like I was getting beat
up at a point in time I'm like I might
as well have a pimp you know and baby
daddies do be acting like pimps because
they want everything from you and they
don't want you to have nothing no
some of them
do you think there's any chance of you
getting out of this lifestyle
I mean you're addicted to it yeah
but because you gotta understand I heard
which we all have heard
as long as you got a [ __ ] you should
never be broke
so I'm just saying that
cause why be out here broke when you
don't have to like come on now not
saying that you're using your [ __ ] but
this [ __ ] right here is power it's
really power and like I have more to me
than just [ __ ] I have intellect you
know I have a certain touch I have a
certain sound
um
your personality a personality I've been
through a lot I'm a good talker I'm a
good listener things like that you know
it adds to everything so I'm more than
what I do
so you know and but God
he got a purpose with me I know that for
a fact and then two
I also want to like you know tell girls
like
when it comes to this type of [ __ ]
like my grandma say it's not what you do
it's how you do it
so just remember that
regret getting into this lifestyle
I low-key regret it sometimes though I
know some people say they don't have no
regrets I just regret how
I did it at first because that's all
people remember they remember the bad
[ __ ] they don't remember no they're not
going to remember they don't even care
about how you're doing it now they
remember the bad [ __ ] and how I do it
now
I had to do it like that because what
they knew me of it was burnt out I was
wilding out I mean some people to this
day be like you just don't give a [ __ ]
and I'm like I do I do give a [ __ ] but I
had to come in this game aggressive and
not caring because
either I'm gonna eat or I'm gonna get
ate up
and I don't want to get ate up
and the streets is no joke like I'm
telling you like
I used to get into it with [ __ ] a lot
of guys a lot a lot a lot a lot because
they didn't want me making money on my
own
not involving them
I'm just gonna say that
I ain't gonna put no pimps on blast
[Music]
but I didn't had it out you know with a
few
and I'm like who the who you think you
is you know and it made me even more mad
like I want to get some more money like
I want to go finesse even harder now and
just so much anger meanwhile me and my
mom is not getting we don't have no good
relationship still to this day she
looked at me like she told me a few
times like something gonna happen to you
she said one of these [ __ ] is gonna
kill you
and I'm like you wish you death for me
she like no I'm just calling it how I
see it you can't keep praying on these
men I'm like I'm not praying on them
they know what I'm doing they want it
they don't want you well I want their
money
and I'm like but I'm you know I'm grown
yeah but you've been doing this
and you know being young she knew how
you out here in the streets popping up
with bamboos and jewelry and how you got
a car at 15 and 16. you know what I'm
saying like how do you where'd you get
this [ __ ] from hush money
you find you have to adapt your
personality and maybe your speaking
Style with different guys yeah like a
white guy you'll you'll just talk a
little yes ghetto yep less ghetto um
let's hear let's hear you talk to a rich
white guy so hey babe
how was your day how are you feeling did
you eat anything
how's work you know rubbing his head and
just talking to him and like his
therapist and I just let them vent just
vent and some of them is like Oh I like
that ghetto [ __ ] some of them you don't
have to yeah and then if I'm putting
yeah if I'm putting on the ACT they're
like be yourself I'll give you more
money and I'm like oh he like this
ghetto [ __ ] well [ __ ] it then hey
but you know
sometimes I'll have the ones like oh my
neighbors oh we're going out oh don't do
this oh make sure you don't wear nothing
too revealing and
I love it though I really love it
um you would be surprised who likes who
my clients
Asians
all Races all Races so you know they
love it and um
it's just I can't get out of it because
I know
that if I wasn't worth it I wouldn't be
getting it and as long as my intent is
good you know I'm getting the money to
take care of my family take care of me
because think about it I can't sit about
no nine to five and just get a little
bitty check I can't do it
yeah it's like kids not with five kids
it's not enough so it's like
it's not like oh I just don't want to do
the right things no it got to make sense
and I'm a beautiful black woman
your kids but do you regret having kids
no that's one thing I don't regret only
because
I wanted kids
and it just puts your back against the
wall financially yes
they break me and then you know like
spending the time and then kind of like
be like a role model too because if you
if you had no kids you'd be free to go
to Miami go to listen I'll be in Tokyo
right now I would be doing something
different and I always think about that
but I try not to have a regret with kids
because I'm the one who lay down and
kept it you know I could have had
abortion
I got a few abortions before
so if I kept my kids obviously God
wanted me to have them everything
happens for a reason so and it's a
purpose and them kids be slowing me down
because I can be more wild way more wow
just had a situation last night but I
could be way more wild you know but God
stops me
what would you say Don is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
most important thing I've learned is
just how you treat people you know make
sure while you're out here in these
streets
you don't treat people bad because it
will come back on you
um and then two just have a purpose with
everything because you could be making
all this money and it's going nowhere
and
the same way how you get it you lose it
like all of these things that people say
it is really true and you gotta live by
something stand for something you know
don't fall for anything because
if I fell for anything that's how you
could lose your life you know why am I
here how long am I going to be here you
know
who is this guy is it protected because
you know a lot of these guys too they
like to have unprotected sex they don't
care
so you got to protect yourself oh but
he's gonna give me three thousand
dollars and probably a disease that you
can't get rid of too so are you gonna be
smart because I you know I did jail time
too in the middle of all of this I went
to jail the LA County jail and I went
for a year they sentenced me with two
years would have before getting some
money fraud you know running up in Banks
because like I told you
you you doing one thing other sins is
going to come right so it was another
opportunity some foreign guy oh you
could get this we could clear the checks
so I end up getting I put girls on and
you know they don't know how to come in
and play the part like me so they got
their ID took they got looked at they
end up snitching on me so when they
snitched on me I'm getting my hair done
Undercovers come get me take me to jail
I'm thinking I'm gonna do a few weeks
they said two years with half so I did a
year in the county jail
I'm already popping my name is popping
already I'm already single YG at this
time
other girls that I you know that made
money with in the street
I'm running into them and I'm seeing
what these girls is talking about like
these real prostitutes when they pimp is
not around they just telling all the
business
and I have a tight relationship with
prostitutes because we have like the
same background
and um
when I was just talking to them I was
just like these hoes is stupid you know
like this could never be me but I was
like ministering to him and I was like
teaching them certain things and a few
of them then told me like I don't got no
pimp no more girl do what you do
you know like I make my own money and I
don't give it to nobody and I realized I
was more
liked now I could be a Madam if I want
to but I didn't want to do that
I was like I don't I don't want to steer
these girls the wrong way but I don't
know why I said the jail [ __ ] but
you know I I've seen so much and hurt so
much
every time I'm in a real bad situation
God either stops it or he turns it into
something else and that's why I don't go
so hard hard
because I'm like
but now I'm I'm trying to start my
businesses now
I'm you know
I'm getting older now so it's like I
don't want all this game to go to waste
like I know so many everybody that I
know now they got shops open they got
businesses they were Street guys Street
women they got clothing brands all that
so I need to
now my thing is okay who's gonna invest
in me so anybody who finesses or holds
you need to find you an investor period
who's about to put into what I want to
do for the rest of my life because me
with my kids I need generational wealth
I don't want them just to be like oh my
mama was a hoe and a singer and she was
in the streets
okay what else what are you gonna leave
for anybody
and so that's what I'm on I'm looking
for Big Time investors and stuff like
that I got a lot of ideas and a lot of
dreams and a lot of things that I can
make money off of and I could use my
street smart
you gotta have Street Smart
because if I wasn't smart I would be
beat up drugged up laced
a few [ __ ] tried to lace me a few
times and I hit that [ __ ] like
what is this
you know
some girls don't know this some girls
are afraid to say something no I know my
worth so I'm not about to go for
anything you're getting cussed the [ __ ]
out I'm telling you what it is I'm
telling you what I want we're going to
keep it straight up and down I'm gonna
keep it 100 you keep it 100. any sneaky
[ __ ] I'm gone
and that's all it is to it you know
because I do love hard
through all of this hard [ __ ] I love
heart but
I'm a Scorpio you know we love heart
I could fall in love with somebody in
one night
the nerve of me all right thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you
very interesting thank you